Now, what did you think when he said
that we're going to pull out a Syria?
Well, first of all, yeah, yeah.
They just had that, uh, we've,
we've lost some servicemen up
in northern Syria today, um,
today as a result of a bombing up there.
Yeah. Isis has taken credit for it.
So there, there was a, uh, patrol
and we, and we've got roughly 2000,
uh, personnel in Syria.
And for the most part,
what are they doing there where they're
providing a guidance training? Um,
they're assisting with targeting,
uh, uh, and because the,
the air power is incredibly important
over there right now. And so we are, uh,
our personnel are,
uh,
very much involved in selection
of identification of targets, uh,
for the air campaign. And, um,
so we have these 2000 troops here.
President says he's going to withdraw.
And then then some of the members of
administration started walking that dog
back, right. And saying, man, I know
it may not happen right away, but yeah,
they just,
there was just a routine patrol if
there this never really such thing as a
routine patrol, but there's a
patrol, um, and it got hit. Uh,
the military is not releasing a lot of
details because they haven't finished
notifying next to kin, but, um,
numbers so far indicate
possibly for service, um, uh,
lost. Um, and that's going to refocus,
I think Congress and hopefully the White
House on what the hell is going on.
The problem I've got with it
is in terms of withdrawing,
look, we could stay there forever
and not accomplish the task, right?
If the task is to finally, uh,
defeat whatever that means,
uh, radical Islamic
jihadists, uh, Isis, uh,
that shit's never going to happen.
Not In our lifetimes.
We're not going to get rid of that
mentality, that, that ideology, uh,
the sort of what seems to be sometimes
a bottomless well of recruits that they
can draw on their ability to morph
into something else as al Qaeda did,
um, over, depending on how successful
we are in a campaign against them,
they're like, you know, again, it's,
it's, it's, you know, it's like, you know,
step on roaches over here
and they pop up over here.
So I think it's the, the, the,
the biggest problem I've got is,
is that if we leave, we're not,
we're not, um, you know,
it's not like we're engaged in firefights
everyday with isis over there. Right.
We've left that to our allies and our
allies in most part up there in the north
of Syria are the Kurds.
The Kurds have been our allies in one
way or another in that part of the world
for a long time now.
And it played a very important role.
And we have not been
particularly honorable over the,
over the years in terms of how sometimes
we deal with them. If we walk out,
if we leave, then uh, Irwin, you know,
the head of Turkey,
I guarantee you we'll be in there in
short order to kill as many of them as
possible because that's just what the
Turkish authorities are going to till they
honestly,
uh,
that they couldn't be happier with the
announcement that we're going to leave
because that opens the door for them
to then go in there and from their
perspective, stamp out the Kurdish
alliance that have been our allies.
We're the only thing our presence at small
presence, you know, not minimizing it,
but it, you know, 2000 troops has been
what's prevented them from doing that.
So that's,
that's the number one issue I've got.
The other is I have no idea why any
president or vice president or anybody in,
in the government ever,
not this,
this administration or any
administration ever thinks it's a,
it's a good idea to say
we've defeated the enemy. Uh,
when we're talking about radical Islam,
we've seen it over and over again
from previous administration,
from the Bush administration.
Every time they say, you
know, we were, we've done it,
mission accomplished, mission
accomplished, we beaten
al Qaeda, we beat nicest.
That's it. There's no upside to
saying that. Shut the fuck up.
Stop saying things like that. It's again,
it's a self inflicted wound at the,
because now what's happening.
Yeah.
The media is not focused on the
fact that we've lost servicemen.
They're focused on, well, just, uh,
just the other day the president said
we defeated Isis and the vice president
today said the same thing.
Now look what's happened.
There's no benefit to saying that. And,
and, and it's not going to happen anyway.
So, so the goal of being over
there is to assist our allies,
but also to make sure that these radical
factions don't become more powerful and
then eventually affect us and attack us.
And so we can keep an eye on what they're
planning, what they're doing. Is that,
is that an accurate
yeah, it is. It, it, it's, it's, it's
exactly it. I mean, if you look at, uh,
the reason we went into Afghanistan,
right, if we go back all those years,
Holy Shit.
Uh,
and that was because the Taliban allowed,
um,
al Qaeda to establish a beachhead in
there for training and for communications
and for finance and for plotting and
planning attacks outside of Afghanistan
against us and our allies.
That's why we went in there,
aside from just seeking revenge,
I see, was to route that out.
We then stayed,
you know,
thinking somehow we were going to turn
the tide of history and create some
pseudo federal democracy. So
that didn't, that didn't work.
But the reason now for
being in Syria is yes, we,
we have done a very solid
job of beating back isis,
removing their territory and
degrading their ability to operate.
But we haven't stamp them out. We haven't
defeated them yet. They're still there.
And so we've been providing
the support and the, again
in the form of, uh, weapons,
hardware, gear of resources,
training, and most importantly a comp,
uh, combat air operations, air. And, um,
that's been critically important.
If we leave,
I have no doubt that isis will
find some way to rejuvenate,
maybe not in its current form, but, and
maybe not in the same exact locations,
but they don't morph cause
that's what they do. They just,
they just find a way to adapt.
And we already know what's happened in
the past when we, when we left Iraq,
we saw what happened with the
rise of Isis. So, you know,
do I want to stay there forever?
Absolutely not.
But both sides can make a valid argument.
One for Stang,
one for leaving my, I think the
best argument for staying in the,
in the certainly short and midterm is to
ensure that Erdowan doesn't slaughter a
bunch of Kurds who have been working
with us. Uh, honorably. Um, you know,
I don't know how else to say that.
So we'll see what happens. I,
the best argument to stay is to protect
the people that helped us to protect our
allies. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's not in our best interest is in
the best interest of our commitment and
our agreement with them.
Well as is it in our national security
interest to, to stay in Syria for example.
Look, right, there was this,
there's so many levels to this thing
and I'm sure right now everybody's
listening going off. Fuck Sake. He's not
going to disappear down a rabbit hole,
but, but uh, yes, I am. Uh, eh. For
a while there, there was this, this,
this idea,
this was ridiculous pie in the sky
thought that we were going to get the
Russians out of Syria.
Never going to fucking happen.
Russian said the only port for their
Black Sea fleet is in Syria. You know,
w w they've been there for decades and
decades along with Iran. We're not,
it's not going to happen unless we want
to go to war with Russia to kick them
out of Syria.
That's not in our best interest.
So is it in our national security
interest to keep troops there,
to fight and try to minimize
Russian involvement in Syria?
I don't think so because we're not going
to shift them off that dime without
going directly at them. Right. It's
in their best interest to stay.
And every nation accidents own best
interest. Are we going to shift Iran?
Are we going to keep Iran from
forming but too late for that?
They've already got a beachhead there
that they're not going to give up.
And so he got to set those
issues aside and say, well,
what the hell are we doing there? Oh we,
oh we there simply because we have to,
you know, finish the fight
against Isis. Well, I, you know,
at some point you gotta say, you know, I
guess I wouldn't say that we've, we're,
we've defeated them, but I
think we would say, yeah,
we've degraded them sufficiently that we
can, we can now operate from elsewhere.
You know,
we can operate from forward basis in
other locations where we're currently,
you know, based. Great. But again, I
keep coming back to the same thing that,
you know, we've, we've
worked with the Kurds.
Is this in our national security
interest? Well, no, I guess it's not,
but there's something that tells
me it's the right thing to do.
And maybe sometimes that's
enough, you know, that we should,
we should not let [inaudible] have his
way and also longterm wouldn't it be in
our best interest to honor our
commitment and make sure that we,
our allies
so that in the future other allies would
be more willing to cooperate with us
because they understand
that once we're committed,
we're fully committed and we stay
and we stand for something. Yeah.
So what's the benefit of getting out?
Like the people that see,
I think we should get out. Like when,
when Trump said he wanted to pull out,
like what's his thinking?
I don't think it runs particularly deep.
I think it just, I think it's, you know,
uh, during the campaign
he talked about, you know,
stopping the endless wars popular
concept right now again, nobody wants to,
I mean, what the hell? I mean, I know.
And so it will be interesting to see,
you know, what today's sad, you know,
event does up on Capitol Hill, you know,
do they, do they rethink their, the,
the withdrawal or do they accelerate it?
So like when they had the buildup in Iraq
and it was highly criticized but then
it was very effective, like it did do
what they intended it to do. Right.
And it did knock back the enemy.
If they decided to ramp it up worldwide,
would that be a solution to
any of this or is the opposite,
is it better to actually ramp up our
defenses domestically and just stay the
fuck away from all of these people?
Yeah.
Well eventually you can only,
I mean you can only do so much I
think on the domestic front. Um,
and then, uh, you know, if,
if they gained sufficient
ability and strength,
we've seen that from past attacks, I
think then, then they'll come after you,
they'll come after us. And that's just
the way I suppose that's going to work.
But I don't disagree with the notion
because it's, it is hard pressed. I look,
I wouldn't have stayed in Afghanistan.
Frankly,
I don't care whether they've increased
their literacy rate by 2% or built
another road or whatever. It
doesn't matter. They don't,
they don't know what the hell we're trying
to sell them. Right. So I don't, uh,
I'm not against the notion of getting out,
but this one's a tough one.
I guess that's what I'm saying is,
is that the Syria issue is,
I'm real conflicted on because of the
Kurds and what they've done on our behalf
in the past and how they've suffered and
knowing, uh, going years and years back,
you know, having dealt with that
issue, uh, two and a half decades ago,
a long time ago with
the Turks and the Kurds,
knowing how vicious that could be a,
and I don't trust her to Juan as far
as I could throw them on a window. So,
you know, I think there's a
problem there that we need to,
we need to make sure we've talked through
thoroughly before we just say, sure,
let's get them out of there.
You know, what the hell? Yeah.
We shouldn't have them there
and we shouldn't be there.
But like everything else it gets,
it's complicated.
You would like to think that what they're
having conversations like this up on
Capitol Hill, you know, between the
parties, uh, Republicans in the dems,
but I don't think they are.